welcome to game life you know when the
game lego star wars was released back in
2005 who could have guessed that this
offbeat combination of tiny plastic toys
and iconic movies would actually spawn a
series of best-selling cooperative video
games enjoyed by geek kids and geek
parents alike Lego has put a crazy
comical spin on the world's of Harry
Potter Indiana Jones and pirates of the
caribbean this year at e3 Warner
Brothers is going lego crazy with two
major new games in Lego Batman to the
entire pantheon of DC superheroes can
explore an open world it's kind of like
Arkham City but for kids and lego lord
of the rings that's just self
explanatory in advance if III we caught
up with TT games to find out what's
going on in the world of Lego if a lego
batman 2 we're focusing on a completely
new kind of story told in a completely
new way we've got the Justice League
against Lex Luthor and the Joker working
together and we tell that story now for
the first time with talking and then we
take it to a new level as well with Lego
Gotham City and we brought that to life
as our biggest Lego playground ever so
controlling Lego Superman and like a
moment to really as an amazing
experience not only has he got his heat
vision A's freeze breath he's super
strength but of course he can fly she'll
be able to soar up to the highest points
of Wayne tower and swoop down low
Greenland and he can fly he can use his
power to transform green Lego into
amazing new object the flash he's got
super speed we gave you wonder woman who
could fly she's got super strength
you'll be able to do almost anything you
can imagine in Lego Gotham City it's
amazing yeah ma I starline the world is
changed
much that once was is lost for none now
live who remember it you must understand
it's lego lord of the rings in terms of
gameplay it's got the perfect mix of
colorful characters with varied
abilities great bad guys of course
massive battles lots of different varied
environments and some really interesting
to lower key puzzle sections as well
when we can use the sense of a quest
through a hub world that actually
unfolds across the whole of middle-earth
taking you on that journey on that quest
you've got the hobbits and merry and
pippin Frodo of course but then you've
got characters like aragorn Boromir
Legolas Gandalf Gimli it's a great team
of characters and switching between
using their different distinctive
abilities in order to fight the bad guys
and overcome the puzzles is what legged
all of the Rings is all about we will
see you next week on game life with even
more previews of the games that we are
most excited about from e3
you